Peanut allergies are serious.
People can die even with just a tiny exposure.
Unless they take a bit of poop bacteria with
their peanuts.
It’s not your imagination.
Food allergies are more visible now than ever.
A 2010 study found peanut allergies are increasing.
But a new double-blind, long-term clinical
trial found success with a pill.
A prized probiotic peanut protein pill from
poop.
For 18 months, kids took a pill with a specific
strain of Lactobacillus rhamnosus part of
a bacterial family that was isolated from
feces.
Our gut is a veritable metropolis of bacteria
that help digest food, work with our immune
system and just keep things rolling.
Lactobacillus is a probiotic, meaning it may
even help other bacteria flourish in the gut.
Bacteria helpin’ bacteria.
Also in the pill was peanut protein… and
the amount of protein increased throughout
the treatment.
After that, the kids didn’t have terrifying
allergic reactions to eating peanuts.
It’s like a peanut allergy cure!
Now, it’s been four years, and more than
two-thirds of the kids can still eat peanuts!
Meanwhile, almost none of the placebo kids
can.
This is a game-changer for parents with kids
who are like: peanut?
Pea-nope.
No one really knows why allergies are increasing.
Epigenetics, the industrial food system, excessive
cleanliness, or it could be that we’re,
simply, more aware of the allergies now.
According to the CDC, only eight foods account
for 90-percent of allergies -- milk, eggs,
peanuts, tree nuts, wheat, soy, fish and crustacean
shellfish.
It’s important to note, 150 to 200 people
die in the U.S. annually from food allergies,
with about half being peanut related.
But peanut allergies aren’t that dangerous…
47 people die from lightning strikes each
year you’re only twice as likely to die
from peanuts as being hit by lightning.
However, accidental ingestion of peanuts Is
a huge worry for parents, and a pill changes
the whole calculus!
If we can knock down one of these food allergies
hopefully we can move onto another…
I humbly request it be shellfish.
I really miss all-you-can-eat shrimp.
Like.
A lot.
Those lobster commercials are torture.
This isn’t the first time we’ve talked
about this allergy, for more on why it’s
becoming so common -- watch this video.
Are you allergic to any foods?
Shrimp for me.
Sadly.
Tell me yours in the comments.
Thanks for watching seeker, please, take a
second and subscribe so we know you’re out
there.